dragons are cool you like dragons yeah
yeah they're pretty cool
it's so sad they're extinct though
wait but were they ever a thing
isn't it a type of dinosaur
dragon
[Music]
hey guys i'm viviane and i am so
obsessed with pop culture i mean
everything from music tv film and
especially fashion i mean like have you
seen me
even my phone is compact and stylish
today i'm challenging two of my favorite
artists marco terzo and kobol to create
a piece of art that shows how culture
has inspired their artistic journey so
let's give them a call and see if
they're up for my challenge
so i have a little challenge for you
both i want you to create a piece of art
shows how pop culture has inspired you
do you think you're up for it i eat
challenges for breakfast let's do it i
ate them for lunch and dinner oh
ooh fighting words
[Music]
i'm kobol a multidisciplinary artist my
art is bold unapologetic vibrant in your
face very unconventional my name is
marco i make art videos online and try
to make them as cool as possible in high
school i made custom shoes for myself
all my friends were going crazy so then
i started making more everyone hyped me
up for no reason so it was like my only
talent what inspires me is people every
everyday instances color my environment
i basically am a sponge to everyday life
things i see around just inspire me i
guess i get like random ideas and i
dream i actually get a lot of dreams and
wake up and i have a good idea a lot of
time when i'm working on like a really
important project then i get a text from
somebody it's easy for me to like look
at multiple apps on the phone so i can
just manage everything
these two are trailblazing artists who
are really pushing the edges of culture
with their style so i can't wait to see
what they do
hey
come on come on come on in okay
so hype because for today's challenge
everything you see in here is up for
grabs so any material any medium any
paint it's all up for you guys to create
something special and unique so you have
four hours these are your spots and i
expect to see some magic like razzle
dazzle yellow blazers like bring it i
want to see it it's a lot of pressure
time starts now okay okay i'm definitely
gonna go with this uh jean jacket right
here
i'll take the pants
and we can make an outfit yeah we'll
protect them
do you have a plan in mind not yet
hopefully i'll get one i kind of like
bounce ideas off my friends when i tell
them ideas they're either like yeah that
sucks that's gonna be ugly or they're
like that's a cool idea like sometimes i
cry but like they're honest so that's
good so basically what i'm gonna do is
i'm going to plan ahead on this and i'm
going to do price on like rough
sketching of this image just to get a
feel of like what i want to go in as so
i'm going to take the s pen here and i'm
just going to plan ahead what are you
painting so i can do that
[Laughter]
yeah i can give you away my sauce
two hours artists
you are really moving fast so i'm very
impressed at your speed this color is
just everything and i feel like it's a
staple color in all of my work also very
bold like i feel like whoever wears this
jacket
they have to have a big personality
marco i see so much grayscale going on
i'll add the color later it's like
starting up with some angel wings city
of angels when i was walking around l.a
i like saw a bunch like art on the
street so i want to take that and put it
on here i love it like you are directly
influenced by the culture around you yes
exactly well i mean between your pants
and kobo's tops i'm about to walk out of
here with more stuff for my closet which
one are you taking i'm thinking what you
talking about
you all have 30 minutes left
okay oh this is completely
evolved yeah the black outlines changed
everything it's like popping off of the
pants that's exactly what i wanted this
is kind of looking like you have angel
wings and a bird like maybe even like a
peacock of some sort you know i was
going for a dragon oh okay
it's okay yeah i think i'll only get one
like done okay we'll make it the best
leg that the world has ever seen try my
best
not trying to make your heart race or
anything but you have five minutes left
yeah
five minutes
i'm so stressed for y'all i had to push
up my sleeves i'm not doing anything but
i just
i mean i'm absorbing the frantic energy
this is too much
five
four
three
two
one brush is down
[Music]
you guys are dying yes my heart was
beating but i finished what i wanted to
i feel very accomplished which is such a
rare thing when you work on something
yeah so for this jacket you know i i
wanted to really meet at that
intersection of art and pop culture but
also i started to think who would wear
this people that are in the culture so
that's why i added a little little drop
cloth here to give it that really
artistic expression and i just figured
the negative space the color is just
everything that i personally would wear
so why not just go with that that's the
only leg i did
i tried my best i did as much as
possible back when i started i was just
thinking about city angels angel wings
and that made me think of like a dragon
so i did like a dragon neck
and then the dragon led me to fire
and now the pants are fire
so it was like a whole metamorphosis
exactly
i'm into it metamorphosis
it looks so much cooler than when you
first put it down thank you and i can
see a lot of people wanting to wear this
i'm a gemini which means some days i
like dragons some days i like orange
street wear so we're going to say both
of y'all won both sides of my gemini are
satisfied
[Music]
you